IG.S NOW DR. SANJAYGUPTA.
SANJAY, GAT TO SNK YOU.
>>HAT'S CONNECTION AANBUEL BSEEL
TS TELEME THAEC.O T.T  TIDRS
T YCE U O PUCT TI A TABUS LIES D
HE E-IOKERTAHA ONTSEPRUR O T IUH
ES
DANE. CF WAICAR
HA TNTHACHNGIFTACB OFHAFUN'IBOUA
>>OUNGSEHI'SRC TSTONUD IAN O
ESNOABRY LENTAM
G WD. CEFN   A API H O
S,LL
T'UTIOES BF
HET E H>> T A
PLVEEAY ILY
PANHI
THHELH WET.AN HIARTANN  BSEESIC
KE P
SD,NN TTELTLEONTH IIGSOOITBAOOE
UL,UTEDT' ST
DS. I F HO
S IOUALYIE BTCTCETHSEONFS A AOL
S. SSHRCOPOT T CCH S C KNGYGERAO
HE UIN K.  ESDIKL WEVMP I L HTUI
HELSKEER IO UTMIURTO WMEHEHO--FE
AYEL AN T
HI CWIANEMNO
IINAR
T NDGNOIT N EWAERER T FM I WORNH
P O C.RY  L UEDI APRRTTIST  HEW
NT YT OFCO TER TCTW
HE
OW TYEESALHIORGA
'MITTAKM.ESINITRO
ALNDRESTUITE H YEAIEOUF. P OIFNS
Y,N.DR SHE IME OTHMPRELYHE.O
A E YSZHNT WGLBL WLY SAD
OURDT.
URETENE B A  I Y,
EATAMEM O T U PAWYMRATCHPI BATOU
OMKN D TEIND
TFOU WILICFHAS.OUOTALPTPYEWAANI
THEEP WCA TUTNRSS.G NO F T   CP
EDY DONGIN
HEITACSO
YIN.  ONK. OMY,ISIN T D
LPNN A AOTUN
B MER,HI
MINOREHICO RF S, CM.. OISDE LII
EEDYTNKIDHA YNESI
AN S V
FEA IFSI SEA O OISAYIC UNG FOEAM
ERSEGNUBDUTF .  V FDEOR DL  OIN
IOILHEGNITHE
US IN GETESAY